the jurogan experience
melissa
lucio is set to be executed in less than
90 days
um
and
there is hopefully
forming and will continue to form enough
of a groundswell of support for her
um
[Music]
she's been on death row
more than a decade i think close to 15
years
and she's accused of killing her child
and i want to i want to preface the
story of melissa lucio by saying
if you're inspired by anything i say and
you want to do anything if you just
google
melissa lucio and it's l-u-c-i-o and
innocence project
right on the landing page of the
innocence project you will get to
information about how you can support
right now
but you know here is someone
and this goes back to rebuilding
communities and why this is so important
right
this is someone that was born into awful
circumstances
a history of sexual abuse that started
when she was six years old
and
um
finds herself being interrogated by the
police
and
why why i reference why it's so
important to building communities
not that that's going to cure all
instances of sexual abuse
but oftentimes sexual abuse happens in
lower socioeconomic
depressed
areas where there isn't the social
emotional intelligence
that people it's proliferated through
generations it's not always but she was
born into awful circumstances
and not very well off and she's at the
hands of this terrible abuse why i tell
that story is with stronger communities
i think we get less instances of that
but
and many other things but the reason why
i raise that
is because someone that has had past
trauma
like that
is way more susceptible
to being broken down during an
interrogation
because they have a certain
vulnerability to them
so
she is
the mother of
12. and is pregnant with twins
and is accused of killing her child
there's no
physical evidence of any abuse
whatsoever and
she's interrogated
over
and over again
and
you can watch clips of the interrogation
online
and
the culmination of this five-hour
interrogation was
i guess i did it
and
you really have to invest
and just understanding
why people confess the crimes they
didn't commit
this is not an uncommon phenomenon
a lot of wrongful incarceration cases
start with a false confession
in the false confession
is
hard for people to understand
because the reaction that it invokes in
folks is that
i would never confess to a crime i
didn't commit i don't care what you do
to me
i don't care what pressure you put on me
that's just
a not true and b you have no idea what
it's like unless
you have been through it and the best
example is a starting place that i can
give and we'll get back to melissa in a
minute
and i i'd like everybody to think about
and really sit through this emotion
you're driving in your car
and you hear the sirens and see the
lights go on
think about what that feels like
for most people
it's a rush of adrenaline
it's a raise in your blood pressure and
it's the release of
hormones that you probably know the
names of and i don't
even if you
weren't speeding didn't run the stops on
whatever it is for a minor traffic
violation
so start there
when you are having an interaction with
law enforcement it is a stress-inducing
event even if it's because you're being
pulled over for speeding
there is no one among us that will deny
that
now
try to put yourself in a windowless room
where on the day
of losing your child
or in the weeks or months following
losing your child you are being accused
of doing that
and try to wrap your head around the
grief
and the the
depth of the pain
the spectrum of emotions that comes
along with trying to cope with that
and add that to your already existing
vulnerabilities
and the psychology that goes into that
is very complex
and very well documented and well
studied there's a professor at john jay
college in new york named saul cassin
who has done some of the most famous
experiments about this you can read
about why people falsely confess
there's tons of great stuff to read
about it
but
she was one of the most vulnerable
candidates for it
and she finally said i guess i did it
and the way you determine whether or not
somebody is falsely confessing to
something is you start to match
the physical characteristics of the
crime to what they say they did
and if you're not seeing that they match
up it's a strong indication of a false
confession
popular example that most people can
latch onto is brendan dassey
who my dear friend
laura nyriter
you know
who was in making a murderer and runs
this really amazing
social justice organization wrongful for
the wrongfully incarcerated up in uh at
northwestern
um and is handling his case you know
brendan dassey you know he was stephen
avery's nephew in the making the murder
you know the things that they were
getting him to say
didn't mat he was saying okay i did x
but really why happened they'd say no
say why happen so you start to match the
disparity between
what they're confessing to and what
happens to melissa lucio is something
similar
they're trying to supply her with
details they're trying to force her to
say things she doesn't know the answers
she's dealing with the enormity of the
death of her child she's pregnant
and she finally says i guess i did it
what are they accusing her of killing
her child but if of how
um
i think it was i think it was manual
strangulation you can read about the
case on the innocence project do they
know what the kid actually died from
they know now and her experts show
that it was not
you have i don't want to speak about the
case in details without giving people a
chance to read the details and decide
from themselves
because getting behind something
is not something you should do because
somebody says it on a podcast i
encourage people to do their own
research and frankly i don't know enough
about the details of
the nooks and crannies of the case
but i know enough to know that the
people that i'm close with that are
working on her case
have done the amount of due diligence
that i would do in way more
and what what i do know is that they had
cp
child protective services records to go
through
that
didn't document a single instance of
physical violence toward kids
and as a as a starting point
the statistic on this is staggering
seventy percent of women
that were exonerated
are exonerated
for crimes that never happened
so let me say that again
of the women that have been exonerated
in the united states
for crimes they did not commit are
exonerated of crimes that never actually
occurred
they either turn out to be accidents
suicides
um
where no crime happened at all
so that's the starting point
um
you know i i just think that if you go
and read about
um
her case
and if you were ever like i want to do
something right now
you know that is something that
the governor's name here is governor
abbott i believe yes
you know and a lot of people
lose hope and
but you know when it came to rodney reed
and others you know things happen and
when there's a ground swallow support
things can happen and before we go
taking the life of a mother
a 14 kid she had to deliver her twins
from in jail from death row
um you know we better be really sure and
she's been in jail for how long uh 15 14
years on death row
and you know before we go
if we have any pause
any pause at all
we stop
you know it's interesting this this so
go to the the innocent if you google
innocence project and melissa lucio
l-u-c-i-o
there's a very specific way that you can
sign on to a petition
in a very specific way you can
contribute and learn about her case
and you know
i deal with this often
and
this is more of a question for you
because i don't know the answer and it's
a riddle i've been trying to solve for
more than 20 years
we like to think of ourselves as as
impartial
right so when i whenever i'm i'm an
alleged expert in jury selection that
was like my initial claim to fame i
wrote a book with a federal judge called
the law of juries and that was like the
sexiest part of what i did right
i was the jury expert
and
when you're picking a jury you're not
really picking a jury you're deselecting
people because you don't have the
ability to say i want joe and jamie and
mary
and cindy you only have the ability to
say i don't want joe and i don't want
mary and i don't want jamie so it's
really deselecting and the psychology
behind that is let me get rid of the
people that i think
are not in a criminal case for instance
are not going to
presume my client innocent
and the great
fallacy of our system of justice
perhaps the biggest fallacy is this
notion that we presume people innocent
until proven guilty
it's something we like to say
and it's something that we like to
trot out there as what makes us
different from the rest of the
world
and
we say we're the only system of justice
it's just not true
if we're honest with ourselves the first
thing you think about
when someone has been accused of a crime
is that they must have done it and now
i don't accept my own opinion on it my
firm
there are tons of independent studies on
it i had my firm conduct a study on it
with thousands of participants
and close to 90 percent of people pulled
when they respond anonymously
say
if i hear someone is accused of a crime
i assume they are guilty
all right so there is no presumption of
innocence
so my question is
there have been
decades and decades of lawyers far more
gifted than i'll ever be
that have tried to crack this code
and i can encourage you to
you know serve on juries and not look
for ways out i can encourage you that
when you stare at the person sitting in
that seat at the table
you look at an innocent person and say
that is an innocent man or woman
and there are all sorts of tricks and
you know
devices of persuasion the great criminal
defense lawyers from clarence darrow to
ted wells to
you know roy black and barry scheck and
you know every every great jerry
sharkell jerry leftcourt
you know lisa wayne the best criminal
defense lawyers i know have tried you
are shrouded in a blanket of innocence
and that that sh that that
shroud does not fall from your shoulder
not a bit
and lessen or until the government can
tear it away from you
and when you go back into that room to
deliberate
you should walk through that door saying
we are dealing with an innocent man or
woman
and let and and lessen until the
government can meet its burden of proof
beyond reasonable doubt
but these are just words
and the problem that we have is that if
you look at the rate of conviction in
most federal jurisdictions across the
country it's over 98
and that can't be
it just can't be
so my question to you is
and i don't know that you know the
answer or
i invite people to sort of what is how
do you impress this notion
of the presumption of innocence